Hey, David, do you think that Donald Trump's
new tone around Corona virus, taking it more
seriously and wearing or carrying around the
mask is going to help him turn the election
around?
I don't think so, no.
I mean, I think it's too little, too.
You know, for the first four or five months
of coronavirus in the United States, Trump
continued to say everything's fine.
Refuse to wear masks.
Masks are, you know, it's your choice.
You can wear it or not wear it or whatever.
We have 15 cases.
It'll soon go to zero, et cetera, et cetera,
et cetera.
In the last 10 to 14 days, we saw Trump with
a mask out in public.
He keeps it in his suit pocket during his
corona virus press briefings to be able to
pull it out like a prop at anytime.
He has actually said some things that are
more sober, like it could get worse before
it gets better.
And on and on and on.
Will this turn around the election for Donald
Trump?
I don't believe so.
I don't believe so, because, number one, the
cat is sort of out of the bag from the standpoint
of corona virus, even if indeed the Trump
administration is now covering up cases since
the changeover from reporting data to the
CDC, instead reporting data to Health and
Human Services.
We covered that earlier this week.
People know that they're unemployed.
People know that their friends are unemployed.
People know the economy is a catastrophe.
People disapprove of Trump's handling of racial
issues, which is the third most important
issue going into November.
So I think Trump putting a mask on now and
saying this is tough is simply not going to
be enough.
Now, could it still be important as far as
keeping people safe?
In other words, will Trump's supporters start
wearing masks because Trump has worn a mask?
I seriously hope so, because that is one of
the most important things that we can do.
We covered on a bonus show earlier this week.
There's a lot of hygiene theater, you know,
restaurants announcing we're going to close
an hour early to spray with some disinfectant,
the entire restaurant or whatever.
There's really no evidence that significant
contagion is happening through surfaces in
that way, you know, cleaning tables and seating
surfaces between guests should be more than
enough.
So there's like hygiene theater stuff that
does not really seem to hold down contagion.
Wearing a mask does wearing a mask when you're
indoors, avoiding crowds.
That's the stuff that really matters.
And so if Trump carrying his mask around helps
more Trump supporters feel OK putting on a
mask, then that's great.
And I would be crazy to oppose that and I
don't oppose it.
Now, there's one other component to this.
It is possible that Trump wearing a mask and
then more people wearing masks as a result
will increase the number of people that feel
comfortable going and voting in person in
November.
Maybe there were people in November who maybe
were going to stay home, but now we're going
to go out now.
I'm thinking of Democrats.
What I mean is the following.
If you're a Trump supporter and you're already
not paying attention to masks, you're going
to go out and vote in person in November.
If you're a Democrat and you care about masks
and they aren't mandatory or a lot of people
aren't wearing them, you might stay home because
others don't plan to wear a mask.
You seeing more Republicans wearing masks
might make you, as a Democrat, more comfortable
going out to vote in November.
And that would be great.
It would be great if Trump wearing a mask
increases everybody's mask compliance, which
makes more Democrats feel comfortable going
out and safely voting in November.
If the death toll goes down significantly.
That may actually be what helps Trump the
most.
And the mask wearing could be part of it.
But it's a long path, right?
The mask wearing you need eight to 10 weeks
to flatten the case curve.
It's about another 15, 20 days to deal with
the deaths.
And then we're at Election Day.
So I just don't know that the timing is going
to work out.
Unemployment going down, stock market continuing
to climb, I don't think is going to do very
much for Donald Trump in terms of the polls.
It really fundamentally comes down to can
Donald Trump avoid another major mistake,
like the response to the George Floyd protest
was a disaster.
Trump's now more than 20 points underwater
on racial relations compared to Joe Biden
disaster.
Trump's early coronavirus response to disaster,
you know, carrying the mask around now I think
is too little, too late.
The resulting economic damage and the fact
that twelve hundred bucks is what's gone out
to some people.
Disaster.
If Trump can avoid another major mistake,
if deaths do start to go down.
If the economy does start to improve in a
real, measurable way, that will help Donald
Trump.
But ultimately, he's desperate.
He knows it.
And it is now about lying about the numbers
to try to hide them and and trying to suppress
the vote.
Which is why we have to work really, really
hard to prevent that from happening.
We have to overwhelm the vote by so much that
the voter suppression Trump will plan to do
this planning to do won't be enough to hand
him a reelection victory.